c'est la petite routine qui recommence
pour marin qui est en secondaire 5 de sa
chambre il passe à sa classe virtuelle
qui le tient occupé quelques heures le
matin de quoi lui faire oublier un peu
les pesanteurs mesures de confinement si
tu vois les points négatifs c'est sûr
que ça ça devient vite des primes un
pays isolé thé avec du monde avec qui tu
passes pas normalement deux trois quatre
cinq semaines sans arrêt d'appui la
possibilité de sortir après la classe c
la pause café avec son père dont il est
très proche mais cela ne remplace
évidemment pas les amis avec qui les
discussions sont devenus assez sain
quand tu communiqué que tes amis tu dis
quoi
qui dit hey salut ça va ouais t'as fait
rien demain donc c'est sûr que c'est ça
monte là qu'on se dit qu'on est parti
pour demain ça va être quand même
quelque chose enduré à l'adolescence
étant déjà un passage pas toujours
facile le moral des jeunes en prend un
coup
il leur faut donc s'adapter l'idée c'est
comment on peut vivre un confinement ce
que ce soit un emprisonne on vit dans
une société où apprivoiser l'ennui c'est
souvent ce discret de l'ennuyer on le
voit dès qu'on a deux minutes on sent le
téléphone on essaie de s'occuper à autre
chose
mais peut-être que c'est la période pour
réapprivoiser l'ennui peut-être que
c'est une période où on peut se rendre
compte que de l'ennui peut émerger la
créativité pour maxime 16 ans et son
frère justin 19 ans et la cuisine
depuis et que ça commence et tout ça on
cuisine encore mieux ce centre permet de
mettre en faire des recettes on faisait
pas avant qui ceci le fun un baume sur
le coeur pour pallier la rareté de ses
relations avec ses amis et ses grands
parents
je pense ça va être vraiment difficile
pour tout le monde sait pas vraiment
comment comment je le sais m'adapter
son frère lui essaie de garder le
contact avec sa copine par le biais des
applications
c'est sûr que là les deux on a vraiment
envie de se voir pire le ça fait juste
deux semaines puis je sais que ça va le
confinement vont encore durer beaucoup
plus longtemps
jusqu'ici il n'a pas cédé comme certains
de ses amis avoir son amoureuse en
personne parce que le travail dans une
épicerie système juste d'un mois je la
verrai mais le yoyo toute ma famille
donc j'ai pas envie de contaminer tout
le monde juste parce que je suis aiguë
eagles pis je vais voir ma blonde pour
aider à tenir le coup ce psychologue
un petit conseil tout simple et on
essaie d'avoir des objets significatifs
ça peut être un foulard un chandail
imprégné du parfum de la personne qu'on
aime ça peut être aussi des lettres
manuscrits des objets qui font de sens
pour nous marin qui pratiquent le soccer
au niveau provincial tente de garder la
forme
même s'il n'y aura pas de championnat
cette année s'est pas officiellement
annulée mais bon peut-être que c'est
reporté mais on n'a pas des sports
vraiment fait un peu plus quand on s'en
prend
puis surtout que c'est c'est la finalité
d'une grande saison en fait puis et là
tu as l'impression que c'est coupé en
plein vol donc c'est frustrant pour
l'instant les fédérations sportives
attendent encore quelques jours avant
d'annuler la saison du printemps et de
l'été ça freine leur élan au niveau de
développement sportif c'est clair ça
brise d'écart ça crée beaucoup
d'inquiétude mais ce n'est pas le temps
de perdre espoir
certains de nos fédérations tout comme
sports québec on pense à rebondir donc
on planifie aussi pour quand on passera
travers ce brouillard entre loisirs
restreint et école virtuelle la journée
de marins passent lentement mais la
sagesse reste penser au moment où
j'étais jeune et qu'il n'y avait pas de
tablettes y avait pas de et pas de rien
et qu'au final vous trouviez un moyen de
vous passer le temps c'est sûr que c'est
peut-être moins amusant mais vous allez
vous découvrira dans réapprivoiser
l'ennui c'est aussi ça le confinement